look a whole world of cheese at your
local grocery store yet
unless you've been near st. Louis you've
probably never heard the name prevail
only here can you find it in broke form
shredded or as a five-pound block
it's ideal for pizza which in st. Louis
is a flat crispy crust and cut into
party squares we don't try to be New
York style or Chicago style this is
definitely st. Louis outfits and emos
pizza dominates the region with nearly a
hundred restaurants mostly concentrated
around st. Louis we started emos in 1964
we started from the first day using
provel cheese and we've used it ever
since it's just a combination of cheddar
Swiss and provolone
that's what makes females emos when it
melts provel is almost like a sauce it's
gooey and has a smoky flavor and of
course provel is also served on the
house salad and in these kid-friendly
cheese bites to give you a sense of how
popular this pizza is here's how many
boxes they go through this is a one-week
supply but not everyone likes it Pye
pizzeria makes deep-dish pies they count
our president as a fan pie pizzeria
makes a really good pizza and they're
decidedly anti prevail there to provide
this is where Nancy prevents yes they do
yes they did you wouldn't Elise would be
the story the
but even Jimmy Kimmel calls Emo's
terrible I I think I think to make
jimweiss controversy that's what I think
you have any sense of why it's not well
I think they just don't know about